hey this you have to see
one of the hosts of the conspiracy right
wing disinformation network oan one
american news her name is alison
steinberg she has started to desperately
plead with liberals to help save oan why
do they need to be saved well because
one american news is now getting dumped
massive dumps by verizon which is the
only major carrier it had left we
covered when directv dropped oan i
believe we covered when a t
dropped oan
uh yes the at t
spinoff decided not to renew its
contract with oan
oan sued and now verizon says we are
dropping oan as well so here is allison
steinberg pleading and saying hey we
need to come together on this we need to
we need liberals to help save us but it
is absolutely crucial that for once we
defy the powers that be that we all come
together set aside our differences in a
unified effort so that we can recognize
the horrifying danger that lies ahead
if you're watching this and you're
laughing and scoffing because you think
that you're immune to what's coming you
just wait enjoy your freedoms while you
still got them
but for anyone that's with me and is
willing to contribute to fighting this
beast here is what you need to do right
if you're ready to send money folks now
[ __ ] this is a horrible person and this
is not about just defending diversity of
views and media allison steinberg was
gleeful when biden got coveted she
pushed all sorts of different conspiracy
theories she said she was being
controlled through her nest thermostat
or something like that uh homophobia
harassment anti-mask tantrums she
celebrated when dr fauci got coveted she
lamented that he was probably going to
recover she referred to the covid
vaccine for kids as poison she said only
doctors benefit from the vaccines she
interviewed known homophobic antisemite
kyle clifton and uh treated it like he
was a serious person worthy of listening
to his ideas she often would use social
media to encourage the harassment of
specific people she called those who
work at disney pedophiles get the hell
out of here alison this is called the
free market
i support a diversity of ideas
and uh i support the reality that
businesses can decide who they want to
be in business with and if verizon says
it's not good for our business to have
oan on our platform then that is their
decision to make and normally people
like allison steinberg are defending it
not decrying it so no allison i'm not
going to donate to oan so that you can
stay on the air and target people and
bully people and spread this information
if there is a
if there is a
demand i guess i would say for that
i'm sure that you can resurface on
uh youtube or your own website or
whatever they may even be banned from
youtube i don't remember now but this is
called the free market of ideas and it's
supply and demand and it seems like the
demand for her nonsense is not as high
as maybe she would like to believe